you might recall in a previous lesson we
used technology to explore what some of
these graphs look like and we will use
some more technology today to help you
with that
however it's equally important that you
can understand what's going on
just with a computer that's between your
ears okay so before we get to the
computer let me explore I want to show
you in a tool that we used to use just
to explore what is this shape look like
okay I want us to consider this equation
y equals execute we know what happens
for this we're very familiar with this
shape but what happens for this guy so
go ahead if you haven't already draw up
this table for me and what we're going
to do is we're going to try out some
values what happens for different values
of X what does the graph look like if we
join up the dots so these are the values
I'm going to try out okay we know where
x equals zero is is right in the middle
I'm going a bit to the left
and I'm going a bit to the right and I'm
going to try and get a picture of what's
going on so all I need to do is take
each of these values of X and substitute
it I'm gonna start in the bills because
that's just how I roll 0 at an x value
if you put in here well Y is equal to 0
cubed 0 cubed is so far so good I can go
to the right because positive numbers
are a bit easier to deal with when X is
1 Y is equal to 1 cubed which is 1 and
then it's not forget more interesting as
we get bigger numbers 2 cubed is and 3
cubed is okay now just pause for a
moment before we go on
um only did y equals x squared we notice
that when you try that values over here
you got exactly said those over here do
you remember that and that's why this
guy is symmetrical okay
but what happens here when X is negative
1 Y will be negative 1 cubed
what's that shorthand indices are just
an abbreviation what's it an
abbreviation of
negative 1 times negative 1 times
negative 1 a third time great which is
negative 1 it's negative 1 because there
are how many negative signs 3 two of
them cancel and they leave one behind
does that make sense
negative 2 cubed is going to be negative
8 and then lastly very good okay so now
let's draw a graph of this but the
reason why I've asked you to do this
table first before we draw the graph is
now we've got a good sense of what the
scales should be scales need to be
consistent on their own right if I draw
a number line like this and I say that's
zero and that's one then if I have a
spot over here and that it better be
2/10 distance right but when you add a
new axis on your new axis can be
completely different for instance I
could say that's their distance I could
make that like a thousand all right or I
could make it a whole different unit all
together to remember earlier in this
topic we looked at say I don't know time
and temperature or like seconds and
kilometers right they can have nothing
to do with each other so the same way my
X and my Y axes are going to be quite
different so draw me a set of axes now
and what we're going to do is if you
make it square like this the same width
as it is higher then we're going to go
all the way to negative three and three
on the edges of the x-values so that's
these guys right put them on one two
three okay so you can count them up I'm
not going to label them because I don't
want diagram to be too busy in clouded
with details but that's one two three
there's the origin right there and then
there's negative one negative negative
three okay now we want the top and the
bottom to be able to capture these
numbers what's a nice round number
that's big enough to capture all of
these how about 30 and negative 30 does
that that sounds reasonable right so
conveniently I'm going to go ten twenty
thirty like that and negative ten
negative 20 negative thirty okay now how
do I read this every one of these
columns is a new coordinate okay it's a
for instance this one is zero zero if an
X there's a why this one will be have a
look one one this one will be two eight
and then lastly and you can complete it
off the left over here okay what I'd
like you to do is write them all out and
then plot them
can you draw a picture show me what this
thing looks like and then join up the
dots as best you can okay so let me just
say that again you're writing out what
the coordinates are and then you are
plotting them onto your graph so for
instance here is zero zero there yes I
already have him but one one just be
careful like this is 10 20 30 right so
the x coordinate for one is here but the
y coordinate one doesn't take you up
very far right maybe you don't need to
use use a ruler so you can be accurate
mine will be somewhere like there it
won't be high at all does that make
sense I'm going to give you a minute or
two to get a head start on me plot your
points on there and see what the shape
looks like if you join it or like you
were probably ahead of me so I want you
to see how I'm going to join up what
I've got okay
I've literally just taken all of these
and I popped them as dot coordinate onto
my graph the first thing I noticed is
just like y equals x squared there's no
straight line you can draw that goes
through all of those right if you get a
ruler and you try and like align it
around it will never hit all of them
okay so straight line won't do just like
why is Luis x squared it curved okay but
different to y equals x squared it's not
just like a mirror image on both sides
but there is some symmetry I want you to
have a look at this I'm going to join
these up now by the way you may not have
done this I'm going to draw an arrow
because it's not like the graph stops at
3 it's going to keep on going to 4 5 6 a
million whatever so that arrow just
indicates yeah I keep going okay
on the left hand side okay this and I
love it if you could label with me is y
equals excuse okay now what's really
lovely that y equals x cubed is it has a
symmetry it's just different to the y
equals x squared symmetry this one it's
like a arm it's like a mirror I took
reflect across to reflects across can
you raise your hand if you finish
drawing this shape hands up straight
okay the vast are your hands down and
what I want you to do is take your book
your whole book and instead of like
trying to reflect it like this I just
want you to rotate it 180 degrees so
your book is upside down now once you've
done that once you've retain it do you
see it's the same graph did you notice
that it's the same graph when you rotate
it it's the same rep okay so you can put
your book back the way it was so here's
what I'd like you to drop down to sort
of summarize that y equals x square
maybe go back to a page where you have a
parabola right it's not just symmetrical
it has a specific kind of symmetry we
call it reflection all
symmetry why cause excuse has symmetry
as well it's just a different kind this
is not reflectional it's what did we do
we rotated right so we call this
rotational symmetry okay now I promise
we're going to use a bit of technology
to explore this a little bit better if
you've got your laptop there go ahead
and open up the des Vosges and you
should be able to get something looks a
bit like this okay OOP you'll notice
I've got a very similar scale happening
here all right can you compare how I got
this right hold on
yeah that's good can you compare the
green graph to the blue graph green
graph to blue graph X cubed versus x
squared okay this is the shape you can
draw it you can get these two things on
the left hand side the last thing you
need is for this exercise because I've
written up the questions already is see
that X cubed I want you to add some
letters onto there just like we did with
the parabola I'd love you to add an A
and a C like this just like we did to
the parabola and I want you to watch
what happens go ahead add your sliders
just like you have before and you'll
notice as you slide now watch what is
similar what is different okay let's
start with a can we move this around
what happens when you make a bigger have
a look look oh yeah well there we go see
that oh yeah oh what's going on there
yeah it's dancing it's getting narrower
right you see that you see how it's
squeezing in right and then when I go
negative what happens what's that it
goes whoa that's kind of cool
okay what happened to the parabola when
we put a negative number out the front
like this what happened
it goes upside down right we'll look at
this look carefully look isn't this an
upside down version of this it is right
it's the same what we call
transformation you've transformed in the
same way what do you predict will happen
when I change see well just like with
the parabola when you sorry I'm just I
got bad aim of my thumbs when you change
see then look it just slides up and down
okay just like it did for the parabola
okay